I wanna live - Scene Breakdown
What do ALL iconic scenes - have in common?
And I’m not limiting this question just
to One Piece or even Anime and Manga.
Seriously, what unites any iconic scene that
you love, no matter if it’s in a book, a
movie, an anime or even a photograph?
- The most fundamental answer to this question,
that I personally came up with, is that they
all manage to create real - heart-felt emotion
- and my reasoning for this answer is this:
A scene can be iconic for a variety of reasons,
right? - because it’s incredibly funny,
sad, epic, horrifying, heartwarming - you
name it.
But, in the end, as diverse as these moments
might seem on the surface, on the most fundamental
level, stories are all about making us FELL
something.
We love loosing ourselves in fictional worlds
and epic adventures, because it allows us
to experience moments, we could never have
in real life.
However, as any aspiring writer will know,
actually creating authentic and impactful
emotions in a scene - is anything but easy.
The fact that Oda has managed to create so
many of these moments, really speaks for the
understanding he has for his craft and frankly,
without it, his story would probably never
have been able to run for as long as it has.
As we will explore more and more throughout
this series of videos, the most iconic moments
in One Piece all do an exceptional job at
making us feel a certain way and many can
undoubtably be described as tear-jerkers.
What I find truly fascinating about this,
and I think you might as well, is that there
is no one formula of how to achieve this,
and especially manga and anime have a number
of unique tools to achieve this.
Therefore, the scene we will be breaking down
today, will be an absolute masterclass in
how to create a strong emotional response
in your audience.
It is one of THE highlights of the water7
- Ennis lobby arc, coincidentally my favourite
arc in the entire story so far.
I think you know what moment I’m talking
about - mainly cause it’s the title of this
video, fair enough - but I think even without
it you would probably have guessed which one
I’m talking about.
Wahh Goosebumps.
I’m really happy you guys seem to enjoy
this new series as much as I do, cause I’m
frankly having a real blast re-reading and
re-watching these scenes, and at risk of sounding
a bit cocky, it’s also so much fun building
a new format from scratch that isn’t out
there yet.
So, thanks for sticking with me here and thanks
for sharing all your amazing ideas and thoughts
with me!
Okay but now enough sweet talk I think, it’s
time to go through some feels again.
So grab yourself a cup of coffee and some
tissues and let’s get into this beauty of
a scene.
Before we get into the analysis part, I will
do a quick recap, so if you wanna skip that,
you can simply jump to this time code here.
The corresponding chapters are 391 and 399
and for the anime it’s episode 278, in case
you wanna read or watch along.
The scene takes place at the height of the
Ennis Lobby arc.
The straw hats have fought their way to the
tower of justice and start their legendary
walk to Ennis Lobby, where they face Robin
and the members of CP9.
Robin is shocked to see them there and tells
them that she won’t return to them and that
she wants to die, all to protect her newly
found friends from the wrath of the world
government.
This is followed by Robin’s flashback and
the events of Ohara, where we truly get to
know Robin and her true personality and dreams
for the very first time.
Re-living her tragic coming of age story and
all the hate, rejection and betrayal she had
to endure, she fears that she will bring nothing
but unfortunate upon those around her, even
though she clearly loves the straw hats at
this point.
And, what she fears the most, even more than
death, is to be abandoned and betrayed once
again, just as crocodile and many others had
done to her before.
At this point she has truly given up on life.
She once again warns Spandam about the horrors
of the Buster call, who carelessly threatens
to use it on the island.
He asks Robin, how anybody could ever NOT
see her as a burden, when her enemy is the
world government itself, pointing at the flag
on top of the tower of justice, asking Luffy
whether he truly understands WHO he is facing
here.
Luffy however coldly replies that he understands
very well who Robin’s enemies are - and
without so much as a hint of uncertainty,
he orders Usopp to shoot down the World Government’s
flag towering over the island.
Usopp steps forward and burns down the flag,
while all of the straw hats watch with stoic
faces.
With this, the straw hats have now officially
declared war on the world, and thus taken
away Robin’s reason for protecting and rejecting
them.
Then, Luffy tells Robin to say that she wants
to live.
Recalling her tragic past, Saul’s final
words to her that she will surely find Nakama
one day and finally Usopp asking her to trust
in Luffy, she finally breaks free of her mental
prison and shouts her dream.
After this, Franky declares his love for the
straw hats as well and destroys the plans
for the Pluton.
Then the bridge lowers and the straw hats
as well as CP9 prepare for battle.
Okay, so what makes this scene so special?
How is Oda able to create such an intense
amount of emotional response with this moment
here.
There are a couple of things I want to get
into here, but the most fundamental element
I believe is emotional contrasting.
What makes Robin’s words SO powerful, is
not the words themselves, but the chain of
emotional sequences leading up to that moment.
At the outset of Ennis Lobby, we have grown
to more or less accept Robin as a part of
the crew.
She has traveled with the straw hats to the
sky islands and established a nice presence
on the ship.
However, her character is still shrouded in
much mystery and neither we the reader, nor
the crew really knows whether it’s okay
to fully trust her as an ally yet.
Her abduction by the CP9 is kept purposefully
ambiguous by Oda, where we only slowly learn
that something is happening against Robin’s
will here.
Luffy is the only one that truly understands
her right from the start.
His unique ability to sense a person’s true
character and their intentions might even
have been the reason he saved her form the
tomb in Alabasta in the first place.
He must have been aware right from the start
of all the pain and sorrow that Robin had
been carrying in her heart and knew that she
was looking for a place that she belonged.
Thus, he immediately takes his crew and follows
her to Ennis lobby to take her back, knowing
that this is what she really wants.
Even if we don’t know about Luffy’s ability
at this point, seeing our main character this
invested and determined, we can’t help but
become involved into Robin’s rescue as well.
This is followed by the crew’s raid on the
island and their fight against time before
Robin is shipped away through the gates of
justice, where she will forever be out of
reach.
This builds enormous urgency and raises the
stakes for every single moment during the
arc, leaving us on the edges of our seats
whether or not Luffy will make it in time.
At the same time, seeing his newly gained
abilities with Gear 2 gives us hope that this
is actually a battle that might be won.
The epic walk to Ennis lobby and the determination
of the crew to get their Nakama back is a
pure firework of euphoric shivers.
However, this is immediately countered by
Robin’s sudden anger and her declaration
that she wants to die.
We can kinda tell that there is more going
on here, that she does indeed want to be saved,
but why in the world does she behave this
way?
This is when we finally get the flashback
into her past, the harsh and lonely childhood
she had, how she lost the only place that
ever accepted her and how she had been on
the run from the world at large for her entire
life having no-one to turn to.
Confronted with, in my opinion, the most tragic
backstory of any straw hat, we get punched
in the gut with a wave of sadness, pity and
dawning comprehension of who Robin truly is
as a person.
Suddenly, we understand her character fully
and it makes the events until now and the
current situation just the more impactful
and engaging.
- Now, me stopping the clip right at this
moment, might have made you twitch a little,
or maybe you even felt annoyed, wanting to
see what happens next - how Robin reacts to
this, even though you already know what will
happen.
That is the type of engagement you want to
reach as a writer when it comes to capturing
your audience.
This moment is CHARGED with anticipation and
emotion and is what makes it so memorable.
You can’t help but see what happens next.
This of course makes Robins words the ultimate
catharsis after building up the tension towards
this scene for countless chapters, while at
the same time setting the mood for the second
half of the arc and the fights that follow.
We are 110% involved in this mission to save
Robin now and want to see our heroes succeed
against an amazing cast of antagonists.
Now, moving on to the scene itself, one of
the things that stood out to me the most here,
was the crazy amount of symbolism it contained.
In general, Oda loves filling his story with
symbols and references.
Some are small and arc-specific, while others
span the entirety of the story.
There are some rather obvious symbols here,
like the walk to the tower, which directly
references the walk to along park or Usopp
shooting down the flag, which is generally
known to be a declaration of war throughout
history.
But the flag itself, ALSO symbolises a lot
here.
The world government as a whole and the political
system behind it.
It represents the power of the world and the
weight it has towering over the entire island
- and more specifically over Robin.
Thus, burning it down does not only mean the
straw hats declaring war on the world, but
it also symbolises the influence that the
government had on Robin vanishing by burning
her doubts and fears to ashes.
The fire itself meanwhile is therefore a literal
light in the darkness for her, as she finally
accepts and understands that Luffy and the
crew truly have come solely for her sake and
with no ulterior motives.
She is truly able to trust someone again for
the first time since loosing her home.
The anime does an especially wonderful job
here at visualising this, showing her leaving
behind her darkness and going into the light.
Fantastic visual symbolism here where she
finally is able to join her friends with all
she is.
This transition also includes another symbol
of the Water 7 and Ennis Lobby arc over all:
Masks.
What they represent, is pretending to be someone
you are not and literally putting on a false
face.
We can see this with Franky, the CP9 and of
course Usopp.
But Robin in many ways also is putting on
a mask throughout the arc, trying to push
Luffy and the others away.
In this scene, Luffy breaks that mask and
she is able to show her true face and true
intentions, finally being the person she really
is.
Thus the ‘I want to live’ moment stands
in direct contrast to the ‘I want to die’
moment just a little earlier, hammering home
the impact the straw hats’ actions and words
have had on her in this short amount of time.
She has accepted that she is actually worth
something and that she is worth to be cared
for and rescued by her friends.
Meanwhile, the golden snail held by Spandam
and the destructive Buster Call it can summon
symbolise Robin’s traumatic childhood and
all her suffering that she had to go through
by having to experience it.
And finally, I think it’s fair to say that
the tower of justice itself also is a symbol.
The name seems to be quite ironic at first,
since it seems to show the hypocrisy and twisted
sense of justice of the world government.
However, with Oda putting in another twist
here, at the end of the arc, the tower of
justice has actually lived up to its name,
as Robin truly does get what she deserves:
Freedom, a new family that loves her and a
place that she belongs.
I would say that it’s a bit cheesy, but
that stuff is just so damn powerful.
Damn you Oda.
Now, how is the character’s body language
& the dialog in this scene implemented?
Well I think the portrayal of Robin’s emotion
speaks for itself.
The facial expressions and the conflict within
her are wonderfully drawn by Oda and the anime
also does a great job at capturing her emotional
transformation.
The way she is finally able to cry and let
out all the emotions that she had suppressed
for so long are simply overwhelming to see.
And beside that, I think the scene manages
to bring out her inner dialog in a very believable
and convincing way, giving us some crucial
insight into her inner world.
Next to Robin, I think the scene also has
some wonderful language for the other straw
hats.
Of course there is Luffy, who’s intense
and emotion-filled speech towards Robin is
one of the most important moments for his
character arc in my opinion, giving us one
of these occasional moments where Luffy’s
true capabilities as a leader come clearly
to light.
And what about the other straw hats?
I think I have rarely seen a manga or anime
do such a fantastic job with silence as in
this scene.
Because none of the straw hats says - anything.
They don’t address Robin, they don’t cry
out in shock when Luffy tells Usopp to shoot
down the flag, they don’t show fear or anger
- or really Any sign of emotional effect this
moment could or actually should have on them.
No, they decide to simply stand there next
to Luffy, side by side with a stoic and determined
look on their face, radiating nothing but
pure confidence and trust in their captain
and dedication to get their friend back.
Sadly, show-don’t-tell is an important skill
in storytelling that somehow is heavily underused
in Anime and Manga and especially Shounen,
where often everything is explained so everyone
in the audience can get it.
But I think this is a perfect example, how
powerful silence can be and simply letting
the visual speak for itself.
Just watch.
THIS - is what gives me goosebumps.
I don’t need everyone in the crew to say
out loud that they want to save Robin.
This is the way to do it and to get me on
board with this scene.
Finally, next to Robin I think it’s also
worth mentioning the change we see in some
other characters in this moment.
Franky for instance finally completely changes
from antagonist to ally in this moment, being
deeply moved and showing his true colors as
well as his affection for the straw hats here.
This results in him destroying the plans of
Pluton and fully following into the steps
of his beloved master Tom, who worked for
the former pirate king Roger during his time.
A quite overlooked moment I believe.
Spandam of course changes from a sense of
superiority and arrogance to fear and panic
once the flag is taken down and while his
character might be annoying beyond help, it
does a wonderful job at getting us fired up
for his defeat and also shaping Lucci to be
the way cooler and more threatening antagonist
of this arc.
And speaking of Lucci, his face in this scene
goes from indifferent and annoyed to full
ecstasy and blood thirst, something that hypes
up the second half of the arc and his later
encounter with Luffy even more.
The scene is also heavily accented by a great
use of sound effects and music.
The flag of the world government flying heavily
in the wind, the silence as Usopp shoots down
the flag, the sound of the flames mixing in
with Robins tears as well as the music when
Robin finally breaks free are all greatly
chosen and do the scene justice I think.
Also, special probs to Luffy’s and Robin’s
voice actors, both of which do a wonderful
job here carrying the heavy emotions in this
scene with their performance.
One thing I think is not optimal though is
Spandam’s VA.
I’m not exactly sure what it is, but I think
there was more potential here to portray him
in a more unpredictable and threatening way,
compared to the mostly comic voice we got
for him in the end.
Just a side note.
The last thing I want to look at is the framing
in this scene.
In general, Ennis Lobby has great framing
and camera movement all over.
However there are some things that stood out
to me.
The scene opens up with a wide shot of Ennis
lobby showing the literal and metaphorical
chasm between Robin and the crew, isolating
her from her friends.
I think this is quite purposefully done here
and I simply love the effect it has on the
reader.
In general of course, the entire island’s
theme is focused around these monstrous structures
there, showing the power of the world government
and giving the stage an epic feel.
Thus, when showing Ennis lobby even smaller
before the enormous gates of justice with
the world government icon on it and when robin
says, that no-one has allowed her to follow
her own dreams, the giant iron gates tower
threateningly over the entire moment.
The same goes for the government flag that
Spandam points up to, overlooking the entire
scene as a sort of protective force.
And I also am a sucker for this panel here,
where the straw hats stand at the edge of
the abyss - absolutely fearless - staring
down the CP9.
And the way that the CP9 members mirror that
pose in just the same way, creates a fantastic
sense of balanced opposition and contrast.
Not only does it foreshadow the battle, but
also the similarity between both groups, with
the CP9 being a “more evil” version of
the straw hats.
And last but not least, Luffy’s and Robin’s
matching close up shots, with Robin answering
her captains call and fully becoming part
of his crew - Beautiful.
So, what is the overall purpose of this scene?
And how does it fit into the context of the
story?
Of course Ennis Lobby as an arc overall plays
a major roles in building the world and driving
the story forward, but focusing on just this
one scene here, I think, that if there is
one thing in particular it achieves above
all else is that it gives major development
to four of the straw hats: Robin, Luffy, Usopp
and Franky.
Let’s look at this list from last to first
- you know so we have the more dramatic ending
for this video - storytelling.
So let’s start with Franky.
There is not too much focus on his character
in this sequence and yet, in retrospect it
is fairly obvious that Oda is already shaping
Franky to become a straw hat here.
Witnessing this incredibly emotional and powerful
moment between the straw hats serves as a
sort of breaking point for him, where he also
is finally able to drop his mask and show
his emotional and kind-hearted side, already
declaring his love for the crew.
By burning the plans of the pluton before
Spandam’s and the CP9’s eyes, he mimics
Luffy’s declaration of war on the government
and thus qualifies himself to join them at
the end of the arc.
In general, I believe that Franky’s arc
here on Ennis Lobby is quite underrated, which
is to be expected when it’s overshadowed
by Robin’s incredible story line.
But nonetheless, I think it’s important
to appreciate how subtly Oda turns his character
around in this moment.
Then of course we have - Usopp.
The entirety of Ennis Lobby serves as Usopp’s
redemption arc after defying Luffy and leaving
the crew on Water 7.
While there are many moments, that are important
to his re-establishment as a member of the
straw hats, like on the sea train with Robin
or later at the port, this scene here, where
he without hesitation follows Luffy’s orders
to declare war on the world, might be the
most important for him in terms of symbolism
and impact.
He shows us that he now fully accepts Luffy
as his captain and makes another step to becoming
a brave warrior of the sea.
And while the flag scene is definitely anything
BUT underrated, the role Usopp plays in it
definitely is, I believe.
Next, we of course have to talk about Luffy.
As mentioned before, his speech here at the
tower of justice is one of the best moments
for his role as captain of the crew.
Oftentimes, Luffy shows his thoughts and emotions
through actions and fighting.
Here however, he actually finds exactly the
right words one would expect from a captain
and future pirate king, and it’s one of
the moments I always remind people off, whenever
they say that Luffy is not a good leader.
The point is, that Luffy is BECOMING a good
leader and it’s moments like these that
show this growth.
When it counts Luffy can loose his naivety
and easy-going nature and become serious.
And it’s moments like this one here or the
one where he gives Nami his hat, where I think
most of us gain the most respect for Luffy
as a main character.
And that brings us back to Robin.
The way Oda shows her moment of liberation
in this scene and how he builds up all that
emotion and suspense for her character is
simply one of my favourite moments in One
Piece and the reason that this video easily
deserves a spot in this series of videos.
Robin in this moment becomes a full-fledged
straw hat and her development from Alabasta
-
until this moment is one of my favourite character
arcs of all time.
Robin breaking out of her depression and seeing
how Saul’s words have come full circle is
a powerful moment to witness.She
now finally has found a place that she belongs
to after loosing the scholars on Ohara and
for the first time she is able to rely fully
on someone else.
In this moment, Robin is prepared to live
life to its fullest.
Now, while Luffy’s speech in this scene
is incredibly touching and powerful, coming
from the hero of our story, I think it is
quite surprising that another iconic moment
in One Piece is another speech.
However, it doesn’t come from Luffy or any
other of our heroes, but from none other than
the main villain of the story: Blackbeard’s
speech on Gaia.
We will discuss this epic moment in the next
video, so stay tuned for that.
Thanks guys, peace.